y'a film dont je voudrais vous parler
aussi
c'est les mains sales pourrez vous en
parler d'abord parce que c'est un des
personnages les mieux construit que j'ai
eu à jouer et finalement c'est me macéra
et ensuite parce qu'il ya eu des espèces
de destins bizarre autour de du fait que
je joue les massages je devais d'abord
joué la pièce au théâtre
sartre m'avait contacté et je devais
vraiment créé le personnage au théâtre
et je n'ai pas pu parce que j'avais
d'autres engagements avec une tournée et
j'avais un délit trop trop élevé à payer
enfin bref je n'ai pas pu créer la pièce
au théâtre françois donc françois
perrier a créé la pièce
et quand françois un an après est parti
pour jouer la pièce lui à son tour en
tournée on m'a demandé de jouer de rôle
à paris j'ai accepté seulement à ce
moment là je devais faire rendez vous de
juillet c'est jacques becker à ce moment
là qui m'a empêché en estimant que
c'était trop dans la journée dans la
même journée de faire les mains sales
le soin et rendez vous de juillet
l'après-midi et une seconde fois j'étais
obligé de refuser à sartre de faire les
mains sales et ce n'est que deux ans
plus tard que rivère ce m'a demandé de
faire le film et j'ai accepté d'abord
parce que le rôle était merveilleux et
ensuite parce que vraiment ce rôle me
revenait toujours d'ailleurs abondé
massage vrai vous raconter une histoire
une anecdote assez amusante nous avons
tourné ce film là dans une ambiance très
agréable avec le merveilleux comédien
qu'est pierre brasseur et il s'est passé
une chose tendance à la sortie du film
un journal qui est de gauche ou de
droite je suis plus très bien et qui
s'appelle l'humanité je vois l'humanité
nous a accusés pierre et moi pas sartre
donc pire et moi nous a accusés d'avoir
fait de la politique et nous a menacés
mais carrément menacé
je suis très exactement du texte mais
c'était assez étrange
c'était d'écrire en première page de
l'humanité c'était écrit
lorsque staline nous aidant nous
prendrons le pouvoir pierre brasseur et
daniel gélin il leur en cuir a alors
j'ai téléphoné
bien j'ai dit non mais tout ça c'est pas
rassurant tous invités t'inquiète pas ça
va s'arranger
bref toute façon ça nous a fait une
publicité extraordinaire l'humanité nous
a fait oublier
c'était extraordinaire pour la sortie du
film et vu que de toute façon staline
après a été complètement dégradée je
crois que maintenant nous n'avons plus
rien à craindre
ce qui est amusant c'est que tous les
passages politique de ce film que sartre
avait dialogué pierre et moi nous nous
comprenions absolument rien
mais c'était un tel point que lorsque
nous avions ces scènes politiques bien
et moi nous étions obligés observé aussi
de mon fait champ contrechamp pas en ce
moment je suis en face de vous mais si
c'est au cinéma il ya un brasseur de
l'autre côté
alors quand c'était sur moi et bien moi
qui ne comprenaient pas de telles
j'avais pris simplement un morceau du
découpage et je l'avais accroché à
l'épaule de pierre est tout simplement
je lisais le texte et quand c'était le
plan sur pierre et bien lui à son tour
avait accroché sylla s'est il avait
accroché le texte de sartre et il lisait
et lui d'ailleurs était beaucoup plus à
droite moi bien qu'il avait trouvé un
truc qui fumait la pipe et c'était
beaucoup plus adroit pour lui pour plus
malins savent pas ils avaient l'air de
jeter un petit regard distrait comme ça
sur mon épaule mais c'est parce qu'il
fumait la pipe pour les housses et un
truc ça
d'ailleurs il est très très bon là il
est très très mal bref c'est ce qui est
étonnant c'est que c'est à cause de ces
scènes là une nous avons été accusés
pierre m
bref vous allez voir je plaisante sur ce
film parce que ce sont des anecdotes
nocera vous allez voir ce film qui est à
mon avis restera sur les problèmes
politiques restera un classique